- [Narrator] In the last few videos
we talked about the Greco Persian wars
or we could say the
Persian invasion of Greece.
And in the first wave, the
first Persian invasion,
the Athenians were able
to stop them at Marathon.
And then in the second Persian invasion
led by Xerxes they were able to route
the Persian navy at Salamis
and eventually get rid of
the Persians all together
at Plataea in 479 BCE.
So at that point the Greeks,
especially the city-states,
the powerful city-states
of Sparta and Athens,
they're fighting on the same side.
But as we'll see in this video
this all starts to break down
and they will eventually
be at war with each other
and a very ugly war.
You know a lot of times when
we think about these things
thousands of years later it
might seem somewhat romantic,
the stuff of stories and adventures,
but these things are ugly,
people are getting killed,
people are getting tortured,
civilians are dying,
whole cities are being destroyed.
Now whenever we talk about history
it's very important to think about
where your story is coming from
and you should always
have a nice dose of doubt
on what were the motivations
of the person who wrote it
or how much can they
really know about things.
And when we talked about
the Persian invasions
of Greece, or the Greco-Persian wars,
that was coming to us from
someone who is often known
as the father of history,
I guess that's a very
Greco-centric perspective,
but that is Herodutus.
And now we're going to
start getting our accounts
from someone who wrote the famous history
of the Peloponnesian War
and that is Thucydides.
And they're so closely linked,
especially because they're giving history
of essentially this fifth century BCE
that this is actually a
double bust of the two,
Herodutus and Thucydides.
So once again a lot of the story
that I'm about to tell,
is coming via Thucydides.
So as soon as the Persians are,
they've been defeated, they leave.
You might remember that the Athenians
had to escape to Salamis,
that's where you also had
the naval route of the Persian navy,
and so the Athenians decide hey let's move
back to Athens.
And in deciding to move back to Athens,
right over there, they
say okay well we want
to build a wall around
Athens in case anyone else
wants to invade us.
And you might say okay maybe
they are somewhat concerned
about the Persians, but
you could also argue
that they are somewhat
concerned about the Spartans
who are famous for having
this very powerful army.
And so they start the construction
on what's often called the long wall
and it's a way for them to have access
to the sea and to protect their city
in the event of a siege.
Now if you take the other side,
if you think about what's going on
in the minds of the Spartans,
they are thinking okay
you know for a long time
we were really the dominant military power
but what we've just seen
with the Greco-Persian wars
is this Athenian navy
is actually quite strong
and in some ways, in fact in a lot of ways
you can argue that they are the ones
that were able to beat off
the Persians at Salamis.
That the navy was essential there.
So Sparta's feeling a
little bit threatened.
And in particular they don't like the idea
of this wall because here you
have the city-state Athens
with this very strong navy,
now they're building a wall.
Sparta says hey if they have a wall
it's going to be very hard
for us if they don't do
what, you know, if they start
exerting too much influence,
it's going to be hard for
us to take down Athens.
They instead suggest hey Athens
why don't you build a wall
at the Isthmus of
Corinth, right over here.
You might notice the geography of Greece.
You have this little, I
guess you could call it
this little strip of land that connects
the mainland I guess you could say,
to this peninsula, this
very large peninsula
which is called Peloponnese,
which is where Sparta is.
And you could imagine that this is
a very strategic location.
Anyone who wants to
conquer the Peloponnese
by land is going to have
to go through there.
The Athenians are of
course no, we care about
protecting ourselves and so they start
to build this wall to protect themselves
which the Spartans already
are not so happy about.
Now the other thing that the Athenians do,
they continue to build
up their naval power.
They see hey this is a very useful thing.
They start connecting
with a bunch of allies
around the Aegean, some on islands,
some on the coast of Anatolia over here.
And they meet on this island of Delos
which you can't see here.
It's a very small island.
And they all agree to
contribute their shared navies
and to contribute money
in order to continue
to fight off the Persians
wherever they are.
You know these Persians
did this injustice to us.
Now let's go on the offensive.
And they form what is
called the Delian League.
Now once again Sparta is
not so happy about this
because more and more it becomes clear
that this Delian League, Athens isn't just
a participant in the Delian League,
Athens is starting to
run the Delian League.
And when people try to drop
out of the Delian League
over time Athens starts to exert itself.
So the Delian League is really starting
more and more and more
into an Athenian empire.
So once again Athens proved itself,
its navy proved itself to be
very powerful in this war.
Sparta's getting insecure.
Athens doesn't listen to
Sparta about this wall
and decides to start building it.
Sparta's feeling even more insecure.
Athens is starting to
create this Delian League
which is really an Athenian empire,
even more insecure.
And it kind of gets a little
bit more intense in 464.
So there are some accounts that Sparta
around this time was already planning
to invade Athens.
To say hey these folks
are getting too powerful,
let's just put them in their place.
But at around that time, in 464,
you have a major earthquake in Sparta.
And so it demolishes
large parts of the city.
And when that earthquake happens,
the Spartan Helots who I guess
the best way you can view
them, they are slaves
and I encourage you to
read more about them.
They were treated horribly.
And in Sparta the accounts
are that there were seven
of these Helots, of these
slaves, for every Spartan.
And so the Helots start a revolt
and Sparta goes to the other city-states
of Greece and says help
us put down this revolt
that happened right after our earthquake.
And so Athens agrees.
They send 4,000 citizen
soldiers to Sparta.
The citizen soldiers are famous Hoplites
to help put down the revolt.
But once again Sparta is feeling insecure.
They say hey why did
they send these soldiers.
Maybe they say they want
to put down this rebellion,
but we Sparta we're at kind
of a fairly vulnerable state
right here, what if they
Athenians took the side
of the Helots.
Well then they might be
able to take over Sparta.
So they send the Athenian Hoplites back.
They said you know we
don't need your help.
And so you can imagine the Athenians now
are starting to take significant offense
to how the Spartans are treating them.
And then you fast
forward a little bit more
to 459 BCE and you have
two allies of Sparta,
Megara and Corinth and they're right
in this very strategic location,
that little land, that land connection
that land bridge between the mainland
and the Peloponnese and there is a dispute
between these two allies of Sparta,
between Corinth and Megara.
And Athens decides to intervene
and form an alliance with Megara.
Well you can imagine
you know this insecurity
has been building up in Sparta
for at this point over a decade
and so it all comes to head
and they start having skirmishes
and they start essentially going
to war with each other.
They have these sporadic skirmishes
over the next 15 years.
And this period right over here
from roughly 460 or 459,
for the next 15 years,
this is often referred to as
the First Peloponnesian War
because once again you have Sparta
and its allies starting to get into
all of these skirmishes
with Athens and its allies.
But this isn't the Peloponnesian War.
The Peloponnesian War is going to come
a little bit about 15 years later.
The first Peloponnesian
War that we were just
talking about, that eventually ends
what's called a 30 years
peace, peace treaty
which only lasts for 15 years.
But the whole time the Athenians,
their navy is growing more powerful,
they keep getting in each others way
and annoying each other and
so the Peloponnesian War
which we'll talk about in more detail
will occur at the end
of the fifth century BCE
and it will conclude with
Sparta being victorious.
But in the process most of Greece
is significantly hurt.
And all of the city-states or
the significant city-states
of Greece are significantly weakened.
And so that sets things up for
the fourth century BCE where it leaves
the city-states of Greece vulnerable
to attack from the north,
in particular Macedonia.
And we'll see that actually
several videos in the future.